[Music]
this
is the reveal of the witch in 2013's the
conjuring
compare that to this reveal of jason in
jason takes manhattan
the first one is much scarier but don't
just take my word for it
jason has certainly had his scary
moments but one of the main reasons
jason takes manhattan is ranked so low
is because it doesn't follow the rules
for making a movie scary
and while there's no exact formula there
are certain time-tested secrets you can
include to create a truly terrifying
jump scare
according to this woman my students kind
of uh jokingly know me as dr har
who has a phd in horror so jump scares
are based
on kind of a theory of what fear is
fear is kind of the build up it's the
the time in between when you think
something might happen
to when it actually happened
[Music]
[Applause]
you can usually tell when a jump scare
is about to happen the lighting dims
the editing slows down things might
start moving by themselves
and the music gets well creepy
[Music]
but those are the more obvious clues so
what is the first thing that helps build
to a jump scare
i call it breadcrumbs you get some type
of indication
that something scary may be likely to
happen the closet door opens slightly
we see a window open there's a weird
noise coming from the corner
there are a few famous audio examples of
this from classic horror
in the friday the 13th series you know
something bad is about to happen when
you hear jason's
or when you hear the famous
in jaws but the breadcrumbs we are
talking about are often more subtle
like in this scene from the 2002 film
below
the character's reflection starts to lag
in the mirror
so you begin to get that feeling that
something is very wrong and that
something
even more scary is about to happen now
let's take a look back at that wardrobe
scene in the conjuring
there are several breadcrumbs that lead
us to the final witch scare
we first have the sound of the closet
door banging
then the visual of the girl walking in
her sleep
cindy notice the camera hardly moves and
the wardrobe never leaves the wide shot
and then we get the sound of even more
banging only this time
the girl is back in her bed so we know
it's not her anymore
cue the creepy music each breadcrumb
raises our level of anxiety a little bit
more like a balloon
gradually getting more inflated until it
finally
pops
there are no specific breadcrumbs in the
jason takes manhattan scene
and in fact we don't even hear the
classic kikiki mamama
until after we know jason is already
right behind them
once we see and hear these clues that
doesn't mean the scare is going to come
right away
in fact for most great jump scares the
opposite is true
you have to make the viewer wait by
dragging out the scene until the tension
is too much to bear
alfred hitchcock famously said there is
no terror in the bang
only in the anticipation of it once the
gun is fired
the fear is done it's over with there's
nothing left to be scared of
once the gun is fired the scene is over
an effective jump scare can take time
even the majority of the movie in some
cases but if done right
the payoff will be well worth it one
great example of build up is this nurse
station scene
in the exorcist 3. the camera doesn't
move at all for about three minutes
while nurses and security guards shuffle
around we know
something is about to happen we just
don't know when and it takes its time to
get there
this scene in insidious is another great
example of building tension
only instead of a single shot we
alternate back and forth between two
characters for an extended period of
time
the conversation goes on for about two
minutes before the demon finally appears
and even though we know something is
about to happen when it does
we're caught off guard
the wardrobe scene in the conjuring
takes place over about
two minutes after the first breadcrumb
director james wan lets the scene play
out
very slowly with a creeping sense of
dread the scene in jason takes manhattan
is also long about two minutes but jason
is revealed so early on in the scene
with no build up
about one minute after it starts so the
only thing we're waiting for
is for the couple to see him 30 seconds
later for us as the audience there's no
tension
no anxiety it's during this period of
build up when the best horror movies
will use a distraction
to further amp up the tension
think of this part like a magic trick
you're encouraged to look in one
direction
while the real threat is happening
elsewhere
in this famous scene in jaws we're
distracted by the discovery of a tooth
and we're expecting to see a shark
instead we get a corpse
in a sixth sense when cole and the
audience is focusing on the closet
an arm shoots out from under the bed
one common and often overused form of
misdirection
is the mirror trope where the
protagonist opens a medicine cabinet for
example
alone at first when it shuts something
is standing behind them
surprise the technique was first used in
roman polanski's 1965 film repulsion
and can be found in numerous other films
to this day
in the conjuring both the camera and
girl are focused on the closet we think
something is inside of it ready to jump
out but in reality the threat is
actually on top of the wardrobe jason
takes manhattan
doesn't even try to fool us at all the
main characters have a false sense of
security
but we as the viewer already know where
the threat is the entire time
this brings us to another visual trick
with jump scares making the audience
feel more anxious by limiting what they
can see
anything that you can do to limit the
character
and through that the audience's frame of
vision
will always increase the the anxiety and
the scare of it
there are two ways of accomplishing this
camera and lighting let's take a look at
lighting first
some common tricks are to use a camera
flash like this scene in mama
or device like night vision goggles in
the descent to narrow the characters
and our scope of vision notice how much
of the scene is obscured in these shots
we have very little space to feel safe
all of these things have what we call
in lighting a hard fall off meaning
there is a very sharp line between what
you can see
and what you can't see that being said
you can still have jump scares during
the day
but these require a bigger build up as
we mentioned earlier for them to be
effective
just look at this terrifying moment in
mulholland drive we don't see the
creature outside the diner until after
an entire
three-minute long buildup of
conversation inside the diner
the conjuring limited how much we can
see by having only one small lamp by the
bed in an otherwise dark room
far away from the wardrobe jason on the
other hand
is standing in a brightly lit times
square where the only time he's obscured
is when two people pass in front of him
the other way to limit view
is by using the camera it is very common
in horror films to limit the character's
kind of vision
their frame of reference where they're
looking through keyholes they might be
trapped in a closet and they're looking
out slats of a closet
and really kind of limit how much they
can see and with that you are limiting
how much the audience can see as well
let's take a look at this scene in the
shining the camera is following danny
so we as the audience can't see around
the corners of the hall
until he does when it's too late
when arbogast is walking up the steps in
psycho the camera is focused
on him so we are also blind to what's
around him
and what's about to happen it creates an
added sense of anxiety in the viewer
the tighter you are and the more
confined you are and the less
information
you have about the situation that's when
it's scary
and camera movements can also force you
into areas you wouldn't normally choose
to go
if the closet is slightly open the
camera may start pushing into the
darkness slightly the filmmaker is
forcing you
as the audience to get closer to it
whether you want to or not
or sometimes the camera will hold
perfectly still
and that in itself can be equally
anxious because we're used to movement
and cuts and things like that
and when a scare finally appears it's
typically accompanied by a loud sound
the sound is known as a sting
a good example of a sting can actually
be heard in the opening credits of
insidious
a film that is full of effective jump
scares
the crash accentuates the moment we are
supposed to be scared
there's certainly a sting when the witch
appears in the conjuring
accompanied by a camera push-in
and there's actually two in jason takes
manhattan
[Music]
but these are both ineffective since
we've already seen jason
there's no peak moment of anxiety that
is elevated by the
sound a sting can only work so well
without a good build up
there are numerous examples of this in
horror films where the jump scare and
the loud sting come
completely out of nowhere sure you may
be startled but this fear won't last
deep blue sea has a memorable jump scare
with a sting but there's no breadcrumb
and no buildup and so while the scene is
certainly violent and unexpected
there's also no real fear after the
shark eats him and the absurdity of it
all
might just make you laugh instead
and after all the work to build up this
scare the threat needs to hold up as
well
in a lot of movies the threat isn't real
but it can still make you jump
oh my gosh the closet door's opening
we're getting closer closer closer the
music's swelling
the camera's pushing in and then it's a
cat
cats have had more jump scares in horror
history than
any monster ever had like in the
amityville horror
when one just appears outside the window
one of the most famous fake scares was
actually not
a cat was this bus in the 1942 film
cat people
in fact this scene went on to inspire
other filmmakers to mimic the fake scare
and has become known as the luton bust
technique named after the film's
producer val luton
another famous example of this is the
pop-tart scene in silent hill
while it might make you jump there's
nothing terrifying about a pop-tart
unless you have a gluten allergy
horror movies are littered with these
types of cheap scares
which ultimately hurt the movie as a
whole because they haven't been earned
and don't move the story forward
the best way to use a jump scare is to
not
overuse it too many jump scares takes
away from the impact of them
and sometimes you don't even need them
at all in fact
best picture winner the silence of the
lambs doesn't even have
one jump scare in the entire movie and
the classic texas chainsaw massacre only
has
two if you're just up here the whole
time
you go flat there's nowhere else to go
and so it's all about kind of you know
taking an audience on a roller coaster
ride of hills and loops
but not trying to keep them suspended in
the air the entire time
and when a jump scare does work well
you'll know because you'll see it pop up
again
and again replicated in newer films as a
tribute to its original success
and the work that went into crafting it
you